so i got a bunch of questions for you so
let's just jump right on in
um i am curious with ryan murphy
obviously i'm a huge fan of his
i love what he's done with
representation and inclusion and he's
given you some really good roles
recently uh i am i'm very curious what
do you get
ryan as a gift after all the cool [ __ ]
he's done for you
oh my gosh i mean talk about
the impossible per gift to get for him
it's just i can't even imagine what the
right gift would be i know it would be
well i'll tell you what i tried to get
him for a rap gift on this there was an
auction of the original sketch
for donald's costume in the freaking
film from 1970
uh and i and i tried to get that piece
at auction
and that kind of thing i feel like he
would value it would have to be like
art or really amazing jewelry i think
the problem with ryan i would imagine is
he could buy whatever he wants for
himself
exactly so it's gotta be the thoughts
and the sentiment and it's got to be
something that's like
really deeply artistic and stylish and
profound you know that's why i thought
that
character sketch would have been a good
one but i lost i lost the auction
i've been talking to a lot of people
over the last few months during the
pandemic i've been asking everyone the
same three softball questions
i'm going to be asking you i promise
they're harmless uh
what tv series would you love to guest
star on
oh my goodness well i would love to
guest on it but i wouldn't want i i
almost wouldn't want to and that would
be succession
um i just i love that show but one of my
favorite things about
that show is that i feel like i think it
was av kaufman who cast that show
so brilliantly because she found
these amazing actors who were so teed up
and ready for the experience
but they were also actors who didn't
have the kind of public profile where
you had any kind of
attachment to who they were so you're
able to just go with that i mean maybe
brian cox but
you're able to just go with them and run
with these characters and
they just capitalize on the moment and
the writing's so brilliant
so i i love that one but i almost
wouldn't want to
i almost would rather just continue to
be an audience member
um the other one is i may destroy you i
love that show so much um
i don't know what role i would play in
that but um i think she's amazing an
incredible storyteller so i would do a
walk-on role for her
got it uh i spoke to jim and zach
earlier today they both said succession
there you go yeah what movie have you
seen the most
either the shawshank redemption
sunset boulevard
jaws alien
or or because of the kids the star wars
franchise
okay last fun question uh what tv show
have you seen
all the way through more than once
none okay you you guys have the same
answers today
yeah i swear it's very weird not the
movie choices but everything else
is i want to know uh jim said tootsie
and zach i don't remember exactly what
he said
um it was a few hours ago pardon me uh
jumping into why i get to talk to you
today
uh i cannot imagine what it would have
been like to see
boys in the band in 1968 off broadway
uh i just can't imagine it have you ever
thought about what it would have been
like
to be in the crowd being part of this
monumental play in a time where
what is depicted in this production is
just not
ever talked about yeah i uh i was very
fortunate that i had
um lunch with william freaking before we
started rehearsals
and he was so as he is he was so
generous of spirit and so candid with me
and and really revelatory in the
discussion first of all he ordered
cracked crab and i was like
yes this is going to be amazing and um
yeah he was just gave me such insight
into the time period and into mark's
life and into the original cast and
what was going on in the world and how
the story was told and
what life was like pre-stone wall what
life was like post stonewall
so he he was an amazing source of
information and
so much of this piece for me has been a
history lesson because
i only knew about uh harvey milk that's
where really my lgbtq history began
and it's because i saw the movie milk so
the more i learned about this time
period the more i understood what was
going on in these months before
stonewall
and this this play takes place at that
time when it's it's that
ugliness and that messiness that takes
place right before our revolution
um so the more i understood um the fact
that this was about
oppression and a group of men whose
behavior is directly influenced by the
way they're treated by society their
their relationship to themselves
the relationship to the other men in the
world is directly influenced by
by society so understanding that made me
appreciate the play on a whole new level
it is pretty amazing to realize that in
68 you have this production
and now you have the movie almost 50
about 50 years later
and this movie is being put out by
netflix in 150 plus countries
and how things have changed so
dramatically
in those in that time um can you sort of
talk about that
i mean stephen if you told me this was
happening 10 years ago i wouldn't have
believed you
you know it's amazing how fast progress
is really happening and
i'm i'm so grateful for that i'm so
optimistic about that
uh what's never been lost on any of us i
don't think is um
how courageous mark crowley in this
original cast was
in stepping up to the plate and telling
the story at a time when it was
completely unprecedented to do so no one
had ever written
a gay story for a mainstream audience
and not only did mark do that he also
wrote
nine completely different characters
well eight gay and one
questioning i guess but the all the gay
characters are completely different you
don't see that in writing now
in 2020 so he he was so ahead of his
time
and uh i we owe a huge debt of gratitude
to these gentlemen
and and we stand on their shoulders
among many others who have done so much
for us over the
ensuing years um and we wouldn't be able
to do it today if if that original cast
hadn't done it back then
100 uh one of the things i think for
young people
who have maybe uh grown up with a lot
more freedom
is that they won't realize what was
going on in 68 and there's like a moment
in the film production where michael is
in the stairway
and his neighbors are coming out and
they're looking in
and you can feel the the scared like how
scared he is that what are
what if these people call the cops yeah
you know everyone in this room is going
to get arrested
it's a completely different world um and
i think it's you know just an education
for younger
people you know there's a part of me
that wishes there was a
a forward at the beginning of the piece
that just talked about what was going on
in 1968
um so that people had some context
because i do think it's so important to
understand
their relationship dynamics that you
have to kind of know what was going on
at that time but
my hope is that young people will
educate themselves just like i had to
when i became a part of this project
uh but i'll tell you this when we're
doing it on broadway
folks who come backstage after every
show and they all want to talk about
this play because there's a lot to talk
about after you watch it
and it was really the young people who
stuck out to me
and they would say oh i know somebody
who's like
uh harold or i know somebody who's like
michael oh man you get him drinking and
he is going to start reading people or
whatever it is
or i've been to parties like that where
it gets messy and people start to read
each other whatever it is so
there was something in these characters
in this world that the younger
generation was so much more open
expressing and sharing with
and i think it's a testament to mark's
writing that they were able to see
themselves in this world
though obviously also understanding
we've come an incredibly
long way in the past 50 plus years
joe did a great job with the staging and
the blocking
uh and i'm curious if you could talk
about how you worked in pre-production
and during production
to work out all the blocking well we
were very lucky in that we got rehearsal
on the set which is unheard of i mean
this was
this joe teed everybody up really
beautifully i thought with the
creative process on this movie it was
kind of unheard of you know and i think
we also
owe a lot of that to ryan murphy and
ryan murphy productions
and of course you're able to rehearse on
the set for a week which
never happens um and and
find new things because judy becker put
this incredible
set together uh whether it was so
immersive in
in finding you could i mean there was a
stack of playbills from the period in
the corner i mean you could get lost
in any part of this set and just be in
the time period
and the costumes that lou irik came up
with were so fantastic
uh and informed the status of the
characters in many ways so we're able to
explore and find
new nuances and then um within the
relationships in the world of peace and
and then we shot it almost completely
sequentially uh the the things that take
place outside the apartment were
somewhat out of order
but we we largely shot it sequentially
and and because we rehearsed
we did it fast uh particularly once
there were nine guys in the room
it was like all right now the camera's
on you for your moment
in this scene and it's probably gonna
for me a lot of times it was one take
and then moving on
so um it moved pretty quick at that
point but thankfully we had the broadway
run and the rehearsal
process to inform that uh i'm a huge fan
of bill pope he shot this movie
uh can you share it the matrix is the
movie i've seen the most in the theater
i was living in ireland at the time and
the only
movies at the movie theater all summer
that summer when i was living in ireland
were the matrix and she's all that
and i think i probably saw the matrix
seven
times in the theater so basically in
between every take you were just geeking
out with them
oh i i mean i've had a couple moments uh
like this
i had the same moment with roger deakins
when i worked with him where
i basically i mean it's almost like a
guru disciple thing where i like
come over to them and i essentially like
bow at their feet
because they have given me so many
iconic and epic memories and moments in
cinema over the years
and uh bill is definitely one of those
bucket list guys
when uh not obviously now but another
day we did a collider connected which is
a long form interview
with roger and his wife it was 90
minutes and it's
really illuminating in terms of their
process together this whole separate
thing
um roger deakins there's no
ego there he comes to work and he just
does incredible
phenomenal things every time he puts a
lens on a camera
no he's a god i'll fully admit it like
we can just say that um you obviously
you've done this production many times
um what was the hardest part about
filming the play
and doing something that you've done you
know so many times or was it
was it almost easy because you've done
it so much the camaraderie and the sense
of ensemble was easy because it was hard
earned having to bounce that ball around
together in front of a live audience
eight times a week for
14 weeks or whatever we did it for the
the beginner's mind was the harder part
coming forgetting all those things and
not relying
on things that worked on stage or or
worked when you're playing it to the
rafters but allowing
joe to help us modulate the performances
and continue to explore them
and and find new depth and and and
and to surprise yourself on a take even
though you'd done the scene
you know 200 times i think that was um
i guess it was a welcome challenge you
know it was fun it made it kept it
exciting it kept it
visceral and it kept it um really alive
i think as opposed to just filming what
we did on stage
i'm curious what you're gonna say about
these next two questions uh
what do you think michael inscribed on
the frame to harold
i never looked
ever and i was behind on stage i was
behind michael uh
a herald when he opened it
uh and so i didn't look
and i didn't want to see what was more
important to me were the reactions from
harold and
gauging that and clocking that and the
reaction
from michael engaging that and clocking
that both of those
things were what were important i felt
for donald to see in that moment
what do you think allen needed to tell
michael
i'm still asking the question 200
performances and i'm still wondering you
know
and i think it's such an important
question to ask and i know why
donald wants to know because i think
this interloper comes into the movie
and he's such an object of fascination
for everyone
i know certainly from donald's point of
view he is because
is he gay is he this guy who's able to
have this double life
and he has a wife and kids and this
successful career but he's also
closeted or or or is michael
determined to have him uh hate himself
is
or be as hard on himself as michael is
on himself
uh the important question that donald's
is still trying to wrap his head around
and
he said so much to drink at that point
and uh it's so
it's been such a long night at that
point that he just can't figure it out
and um you know it's it's like asking a
question at the end of a shakespeare
play
you know i can't think of a perfect
example
parallel but sometimes it's a question
you're never supposed to know the answer
to i i love that these two things just
allow the audience to determine for
themselves what
what they think the level um i would
imagine you guys had a lot of times
a lot of time with mark uh uh and i'm
curious if he ever told you
or if you ever wanted to know i mean i
had so many amazing
candid conversations with mart and i
love him and i miss him
um but i i don't wanna know
i want to know i didn't ask brian i
didn't want to know from brian
i felt like it would make the play in
the process
less interesting to me if i knew what
his choice was
and when you're doing it eight times a
week and you want that
curiosity to stay alive and present on
stage
i mean of course i could fake it but i
didn't want to know and i don't want to
know now
when was the last time you were really
nervous
before doing something whether it be on
stage whether it be a movie
a tv series was there ever a time you're
like oh
f you know god yes of course
i i i get nervous before i have to do
zoom junkets you know
um because in a way it's not it's not
something you've rehearsed it's not
something that's on a controlled set you
know it's a conversation
and it's such a strange time right now
and there's so much out there in the
zeitgeist
uh so it's a kind of a crazy time to be
talking to anybody about anything when
it's being recorded
so i would start with that um and just
meetings i've had honestly even just in
the past few months meetings i've had to
have a resume where you're trying to
find out if you're going to be working
and collaborating with these people who
you love and admire but at the same time
you're
kind of meeting each other in this very
sterile environment and way
i'm almost out of time with you so i
have to ask you uh about two other
things
number one um so what's going on with
white collar
that's a great question i have no idea i
mean
i i threw my hat in the ring and told
jeff easton if he could find a way to do
it and find a home for it and
a way that worked everyone's schedules
and wasn't you know
uh you know 16 episodes for six years um
then then you know i'd be there to to
throw that fedora on and work with that
incredible cast who i love and adore and
speak to
weekly still um but i
you know so much of what goes into that
is is way above my pay grade and beyond
my control you know i'm not going to put
a pitch together as to what the arc of
the show should be or what the story
needs to be or where it needs to be that
it's sort of up to
him and whatever platform would want to
produce it yeah i was wondering if you
guys would ever do like the two hour
movie versus like doing another 10
episodes
that was my pitch is to do a two-hour
movie and just see how it goes you know
and get everybody back together
or even four hours do two two hour
movies or four or
one hours whatever it is to tell just
one
uh story line and uh and just to see how
it goes that's kind of what my pitch was
i don't know if that's like
i don't know commercially how that fits
into the paradigm in this day and age i
don't know if that's something that's
interesting to people i'm not sure but
that would be i would love to do
something like that
uh congratulations on doom patrol thank
you
uh i know that you guys got the season
three for hbo max
yes um so what's going on when do you
start filming that
i have no idea i mean i honestly i have
the only things
that are really real that i've that have
come my way
um film overseas at this point um and i
just can't
lead my family uh during the election
and holidays
at this time there's just too much going
on so
um i hopefully uh you know when things
pick up
when say i i'm hearing that sets that
people are on are really safe and
trustworthy and i'm
hopefully i'll be back in atlanta in the
new year and we'll be working on season
three but
i don't have any official word on
anything i completely understand
i have to rap there i will just say
congrats
on the film i think it turned out great
and uh you know nothing but the best to
you and your family thank you steven
likewise stay well stay healthy and
until next time hopefully i see you in
person